Traductor: Ciro Gomez
Revisor: Emma Gon
Hay un error común:
que si te gusta organizar
meticulosamente tus cosas,
tener las manos limpias,
o planificar tu fin de semana
hasta el último detalle,
es posible que tengas TOC.
De hecho, TOC, siglas de
trastorno obsesivo compulsivo,
es una condición psiquiátrica grave,
con frecuencia
es mal entendida por la gente
y los profesionales de
la salud mental por igual.
Así que vamos a empezar
a desmitificarlo.
Mito uno: conductas repetitivas
o rituales son sinónimo de TOC.
Como su nombre indica,
el trastorno obsesivo compulsivo
tiene dos aspectos:
pensamientos intrusivos, imágenes o
impulsos, conocidos como obsesiones,
y compulsiones de comportamiento
en la que se involucra la gente
para aliviar la ansiedad
que provocan las obsesiones.
Los tipos de acciones que la gente
a menudo se asocian con el TOC,
como el lavado de manos excesivo o
el comprobar cosas en varias ocasiones,
pueden ser ejemplos de
tendencias obsesivas o compulsivas
que muchos de nosotros exhibimos
de vez en cuando.
Pero el desorden real es mucho más raro
y puede ser muy debilitante.
Los afectados tienen poco o ningún
control sobre sus pensamientos obsesivos
y sus comportamientos compulsivos,
que tienden a consumir mucho tiempo
e interferir con el trabajo,
la escuela o la vida social
hasta el punto de causar
angustia significativa.
Estos criterios de diagnóstico son los que
separan a las personas que sufren de TOC
de los que solo pueden ser
un poco más meticulosos
u obsesionados con la higiene
de lo habitual.
Mito dos: el síntoma principal de TOC
es el lavado de manos excesivo.
Aunque el lavado de manos es la imagen
más común de TOC en la cultura popular,
las obsesiones y compulsiones pueden
tomar muchas formas diferentes.
Las obsesiones pueden manifestarse como
temor a la contaminación y la enfermedad,
preocupación de hacer daño a otros,
o preocupaciones con números, patrones,
moralidad o la identidad sexual.
Y las compulsiones pueden ir desde
la limpieza excesiva o doble control,
a la colocación exigente de los objetos,
o caminar en patrones predeterminados.
Mito tres:
individuos con TOC no entienden
que están actuando irracionalmente.
Muchos individuos con TOC
realmente entienden la relación
entre sus obsesiones
y compulsiones bastante bien.
Ser incapaz de evitar
estos pensamientos y acciones
a pesar de ser conscientes
de su irracionalidad
es parte de la razón por
la que el TOC es tan angustiante.
Los enfermos de TOC dicen sentirse locos
por experimentar la ansiedad
basada en pensamientos irracionales
y que tienen dificultad
para controlar sus respuestas.
Entonces, ¿qué causa exactamente el TOC?
La respuesta frustrante es
que no se sabe muy bien.
Sin embargo, tenemos
algunas pistas importantes.
El TOC se considera
un trastorno neurobiológico.
En otras palabras, la investigación
sugiere que los pacientes con cerebros TOC
en realidad están programados
para comportarse de cierta manera.
La investigación implica
a 3 regiones del cerebro
distintamente involucradas
en el comportamiento social
y la planificación cognitiva compleja,
el movimiento voluntario,
y las respuestas emocionales
y motivacionales.
La otra pieza del rompecabezas
se que el TOC está asociado
con bajos niveles de serotonina,
un neurotransmisor que comunica
a las estructuras cerebrales
y ayuda a regular los procesos vitales,
como el estado de ánimo, la agresión,
el control de impulsos,
el sueño, el apetito,
la temperatura corporal y el dolor.
Pero son la serotonina y la actividad en
estas regiones del cerebro causa del TOC
o síntomas de una causa subyacente
del trastorno desconocido.
Seguro no lo sabremos hasta
que tengamos una comprensión
mucho más íntima del cerebro.
La buena noticia es
que hay tratamientos eficaces para el TOC,
que incluyen medicamentos que
aumentan la serotonina en el cerebro
limitando su reabsorción
por las células cerebrales,
terapia conductual que desensibiliza
gradualmente a las ansiedades,
y en algunos casos,
terapia electroconvulsiva,
o cirugía, cuando el TOC no responde
a otras formas de tratamiento.
Saber que tu cerebro está mintiendo
si bien no eres capaz de resistir a
sus comandos puede ser agonizante.
Pero con conocimiento y comprensión
viene el poder para buscar ayuda,
y la investigación futura en el cerebro
finalmente, podría proporcionar
las respuestas que estamos buscando.